Even if you know that your application will only run on
a single core single CPU, it can still be useful to express
parallelism in your programs. In fact, almost every time you load
a web page, your browser is making something called an asynchronous request
back to the server for more information that exploits a certain
kind of parallelism. You see, the web server rarely sends all the
information for a web page in response to your initial request.
Instead, it sends a kind of outline for the page. That includes
other URL's where your browser can find the details. To get
these details your browser then sends other HTTP requests back to
the server, for example, we might need a style sheet and
also an image to help fill out the website. Now if we
were to implement this in a naive synchronous way our program
might run for a while, but when it discovers that it
needs a CSS file from the server it would make the
HTTP request And then pause part way to get the response back.
After receiving the response it could then, process the CSS
file, and then continue with work, until it discovers that it
needs image file. Make that request, wait til it receives
it, and then process that image file. Clearly this is inefficient.
There is no sense in making the browser, and hence
the user, wait for a response from the server While there
was more work to be done in reading and rendering
the original request. This is why requests back to the server
are made asynchronously. And this is really just a fancy
word meaning that we get to continue our program without having
to wait for a web request or sometimes a system
call to complete. So an asynchronous approach, we would begin by
processing the HTML profile just as we did in the
naive approach. But when we find that we need to request
a CSS page, we do so in a new thread. This
allows our original thread to continue processing a HTML file and
discover that he also needs to request a PNG file,
again he will do this in a new thread. When he
gets this CSS file back from the server the requesting thread
can process it. And when he gets back the p and
g file, the requesting thread can also process that. And
the end result is that we finished loading the page much
faster. Now remember, we're still assuming that we only have one
CPU. This means that the computation that the naive approach did,
say this red portion here, can't run in parallel with
the other parts of the processing. They still have to
take turns. Nevertheless, because we weren't idle while we waited
for the web server, as we were in the naive approach,
we've made our page load faster by always giving the
CPU something to do. And it's the programming abstraction of
threads that makes it possible to achieve, both, this behavior,
as well as the true parallel processing that we discussed earlier.